hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
Tara Eriksen you know who's got talent
this girl power
thanks so much this idiot is it like I'm
offensive is it sexist for me to call
even though your thing is this idiot no
no does it I call you an idiot idiot no
I love it
maybe it are me ridiculous [ __ ] idiot
yeah yeah what an idiot
why do what maybe it feels so good to
call you that yeah it does you're just
get it off your chest
feels so good I think you're going too
far I gave you permission and now what
you went from - Wow till I get 60 and
normally people ask on a scale there you
go 1 to 10 right you went from 1 to 10
and then you went right up to a hundred
and everybody got on comfort are you
done talking idiot American video keep
talking while your talk you rejected 30
year old man reject rejected liked it
like the don't lay garbage you know like
like a garbage a plastic garbage bag
that gets rejected into the trash bin
you really think I'm 30 really know how
to slay those those birds huh really
really burning strong bring the heat I
got it let's just move on
I sure the people who wanted to see this
reaction are getting the intro they
deserve spectacular by the way thank you
very much how have you prepared yourself
for the next round I practice a whole
ton it's a tough act so what nobody
wants too many questions because I like
being surprised all right open it sure
is you know one spectator so
[Applause]
Olivia Munn yeah she's only sure is that
her
can't tell I don't know maybe I'm an
idiot hey do you know that's her okay
Olivia could you go take your hand this
one and cover it right over here make
sure you don't move okay
[Music]
we got three Queens on here folks wait
what
I do that
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
the cards are giving birth
[Applause]
visual-effects pan
[Music]
whoa Olivia looks really turned on
[Music]
Gangu
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
No
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
what the my nipples are so hard with
chill oh my goodness you're all rigged
with magnets the cards I already figured
it out he does thing and then he magnet
and it goes under the black thing and
then when he needs it again he does a
reverse magnet thing you're that girl at
the Magic Castle are you that girl who's
watching it goes I can't just enjoy the
show
I just gotta prove this oh I enjoy the
magic I enjoy it he's a true artist he's
no con artist he's an artist - I love
how Simon Cowell just the whole time
when he was talking he was like I like
the first thing it's like oh yeah dude
Olivia looked really turned on you see
her face magic what could he do with
those hands you know what I mean I've
met some people magicians at the Magic
Castle outside of the Magic Castle oh
okay get some pretty easy action
no no they only get action if they're
inside the Magic Castle right after they
did magic yeah exactly it's pretty
simple they just do their show and the
girls are like I like how you doing
magic and I'm sorry if you can make me
disappear because I don't even like and
then he's like yeah sure no problem can
we do it first and make sure that's
right I take I guess it makes up for the
years of bullying they got for your
magicians is there something hot about a
guy who can do magic you can do man
there's something hot about that you see
a guy do magic is it like well it took a
talent well I guess yeah I think it is I
mean yes yeah be like is it just because
he's talented and has a skill or is it
like also most of time they have good
style they dress in nice clothes a very
good way so entertainers very magician
way yeah and then they also can you know
make a card there and then make it
disappear
I don't know how he did this at all me
neither
I can't even theorize
what he did it couldn't Magnus because
it's all magnets you can see the magnets
on the cards and everything what about
the four aces that appeared under her
hand
that's freaked me out that's great like
I get the coin and then I open my hand
there's like six coins in my hand that
these kind of tricks freak me out there
are funny real slight movements you
gotta be real slide that's why ladies
like you you slide right you're like
sitting around and you're like sad and
sulking and then all of a sudden you
have a rocky road pint of ice cream in
your hand because your boyfriend's a
magician this is just I should only date
magicians a wizard you're talking about
I think it's mean this guy can do it to
you I need go listen put your put your
hand are you feel sad today put your
hand on this card and you keep it there
and here I'll turn on the design fell
for you and I take great I walk around
and do some stuff as his hands and then
he like great lift your hand and like
rocky road maybe not a hole just like a
little thing you know in the ice cream
and then I feel better and then it's
like poof good thing I'm not dating
normal guys a good thing I'm dating a
magician you know I mean you guys Wow
and subscribe to the reach you know I
never actually land doing this Suzanne I
dropped it but I did it with pizzazz you
know how I thought I did it right
I don't I don't think you're you know
subscribe to rearrange let's be honest
you could subscribe to me - my name is
tara erickson okay he's wandering around
with a notification that's how you do it
flip a battery okay [ __ ] reaction my
patreon watching
drop it every time okay
- okay yeah this is this videos never
gonna end